how long have you when's the last time
you were on a date last time I was on a
date of like years was no it was I mean
I just recently stopped talking to
someone so it was
maybe a month ago not even okay what
about you who else is single and but
before that it was a long time it was
like a year cuz I'm picky I'm going to
be honest with you picky some of you
take forever to find yourself and you
pretty much don't go on dates
for years and you think you can go back
into the dating Market
date a guy but you don't really have any
experience dating does that make sense
like if you don't go on dates that does
make sense you're not going to know how
to date